el presidente de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador cumplió cuatro años en el
poder entre la polarización de la
sociedad de un alto respaldo con una
aprobación de un cincuenta y cinco por
ciento según encuestas locales con
nuestro primer invitado del día hacemos
entonces un balance de estos cuatro años
en temas a como la economía la seguridad
la salud del covid 19 infraestructura y
también las relaciones exteriores entre
otros temas y ya le vamos a Nicolás
Botero analista político con estudios en
la Universidad Nacional Autónoma de
México Nicolás buena mañana de viernes
Gracias por estar con nosotros Raúl
Muchas gracias Buenos días hagamos
Entonces primero este balance general de
lo que han sido estos cuatro años del
presidente de México Andrés Manuel López
Obrador pues Raúl lo que estamos viendo
lo que vimos en el domingo pasado fue
una marcha bastante
movida con mucha gente pero también como
en un espacio de una especie de
contramarcha
por la marcha que se había dado la
semana anterior en respaldo a la no
reforma constitucional del Instituto
Nacional electoral entonces lo que
encontramos en el en el discurso del
presidente Obrador es un montón de de
espacio de dinero que se ha venido
generando no para los más pobres porque
hay que contar con el pueblo no y un
montón de elementos que generan de una u
otra manera pues un aumento de su
popularidad un respaldo también a su a
su gestión pero estamos viendo que se
quedan por fuera diferentes elementos
como los que tú mencionas el covid-19 no
todo ese proceso que que se tuvo que dar
con el covid posterior la vacunación no
hablaba ayer un poco Perdón en el en el
en el discurso hablaba un poco de ese
cubrimiento a través de las vacunas pero
solamente habla de un porcentaje de las
de las personas de la tercera edad
entonces y en la primera dosis Entonces
estamos hablando de un cubrimiento que
no está al 100% en la población también
una movilización que fue bastante
pronunciada y bastante fuerte desde el
2019 por todas esas migraciones que hay
hacia los Estados Unidos y que tampoco
fueron de una u otra manera
mencionadas no a profundidad en el
discurso vemos Que si hay avances como
entregar Alguna algún tipo de visa
genera algún tipo de trabajo para los
migrantes que quieran quedarse ahí pero
creo que el foco ahí no estuvo durante
durante el proceso Tampoco
Pues hay mucha atención con respecto a
los normalistas de Ayotzinapa y el hecho
de que no se pueda generar una un
resultado
digamos benévolo o eficiente no
solamente para las familias sino para el
pueblo mexicano en general sí creo que
ahí hay varios varios vamos a ir
desgranando estos puntos empecemos
primero con la lucha contra la
corrupción o también una bandera digamos
que una de las principales en lo que fue
su campaña Hace cuatro años también
cuando llegó a la presidencia dijo que
iba a ser una lucha contra contra la
corrupción sin precedentes también
estaba Pues el enjuiciamiento el
enjuiciamiento pues y el señalamiento
los expresidentes involucrados en toda
la corrupción cómo está realmente la
corrupción en la actualidad en México
pues lo que es lo que demuestra el
presidente López Obrador es que él ha
logrado acabar con la gran mayoría de la
corrupción no obstante Pues estamos
viendo que que hay muchos elementos
todavía que quedan dentro del tintero y
uno de ellos es lo que pasó o lo que no
ha sucedido al 100% con hechos de
corrupción por ejemplo
el caso del Salvador Cienfuegos del
General Salvador Cienfuegos que fue
detenido en los Estados Unidos y
posteriormente repatriado en el que
nunca se supo o no se ha vuelto a saber
absolutamente nada por la investigación
de la procuraduría de la procuraduría
general de la república el caso
Ayotzinapa Yo creo que es un elemento
también
importante de esos temas de corrupción
Quizá el respaldo que ha tenido a lo
largo de este tiempo en términos de
corrupción ha sido más por ese tipo de
inversión en los diferentes
organizaciones y en las diferentes
entidades del Estado no obstante pues
decir que en cuatro en cuatro o cinco
años se va a acabar al 100% con la
corrupción creo que es bastante complejo
la violencia en México también sigue
siendo uno de los problemas
las principales violencia contra los
periodistas violencia contra las mujeres
y precisamente la violencia digamos
también como de una parte del Estado
haciendo referencia al caso de
Ayotzinapa Sí mira que Pues todos los
medios de comunicación reportan que en
el último año una de las profesiones más
peligrosas para desarrollar en México
Ese es justamente el periodismo entonces
no es única exclusivamente eso sino
también todo lo que acarrea ese tipo de
elementos Las investigaciones que sacan
a la luz
corrupción elementos de corrupción
elementos que ponen en el ojo del
huracán por decirlo de esa manera al
mismo periodista y que terminan siendo
baleados en las calles de los diferentes
estados de la República Mexicana Nicolás
también hablabas de un punto muy
importante y es la migración o toda la
migración o digamos que se filtra por
México para llegar a Estados Unidos el
caso más reciente y que ha sonado más en
los medios de comunicación por supuesto
ha sido el caso de los venezolanos que
también se han quedado va en México por
la negativa las nuevas políticas
migratorias de Estados Unidos para no
dejarlos ingresar por la frontera sino
por vía aérea con esta nueva ley del
presidente biden en temas de migración
Qué ha hecho y Y qué Le faltaría por
hacer al al presidente López Obrador no
yo creo que México en ese sentido ha
avanzado pero no ha dado unos pasos tan
grandes como quisiéramos en algún
momento yo creo que no es única
exclusivamente los venezolanos yo creo
que la movilización de latinoamericanos
con miras a llegar a a Estados Unidos
por la frontera sur de de de de Estados
Unidos y la frontera norte de México ha
sido realmente
fuera de sí sí
no solamente venezolanos hay colombianos
hay centroamericanos de toda índole
Entonces estamos viendo que se les da un
un espacio para que ellos puedan empezar
a trabajar si se quieren quedar ahí y
también otros espacios para lograr tener
un descanso durante unos días y empezar
a hacer documentos para empezar a estar
en la fila digámoslo así para para hacer
llamados pero también vemos muchos de
esos
ayudas o esos albergues muchos de ellos
manejados por sacerdotes o por
comunidades de la sociedad civil en
donde dicen no vengan más porque ya no O
no hay más espacio o tampoco van a poder
pasar entonces eso está generando una
contradicción muy alta por un lado el
presidente dice estamos avanzando no por
otro lado no lo toca en su discurso de
cuatro años y por otro lado estamos
viendo que realmente Hay un problema
social ahí importante muy rápidamente
Nicolás la polémica en el plan de
reforma electoral del presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador que muchísimos
también rechazan incluso Washington dijo
que esto podría representar una amenaza
para la democracia estamos en ese
proceso desde el mes de abril cuando el
presidente López Obrador presenta esta
reforma es una reforma constitucional
que para mí toca Tres puntos importantes
la reforma de los magistrados pasar de
11 magistrados a siete magistrados del
Consejo Nacional electoral muchos de
ellos y varios de los magistrados han
dicho que el INE funciona con
independencia de los partidos políticos
no y de de y de y del gobierno no el
segundo la
la Reforma
por la forma de la elección que se va a
generar eso es lo que ha generado muchas
suspicacia de cómo se va a hacer de
ahora en adelante las elecciones y la
disminución de una u otra manera de el
apoyo que esta reforma puede llegar a
tener la cámara de diputados y
obviamente el senado ya todos los
partidos políticos le dijeron que no sé
que no va Entonces estamos a la espera
vamos a ver entonces qué